the movie starts with a couple James
Foster and his wife mem who are spending
time at a resort they have recently
flown in from the US to a Seaside
country named Lea James is a struggling
writer by profession as his last book
flopped miserably on the other hand em
is the daughter of a wealthy businessman
although the two got married very
recently their relationship isn't doing
well hence they have taken this vacation
to bridge the gap between them in the
next scene we get to know that Leola is
a very po poor country with most of its
residents living below the poverty line
as a result the resort is fenced up from
all sides to ensure that the locals
don't enter however one of them manages
to get through he is currently causing
chaos on his quad bike the commotion
attracts the attention of James and when
he reaches the site a beautiful woman
named Gabby approaches him she
immediately engages in conversation and
reveals that she is a big fan of his
work hearing this James is a bit
surprised as his book was a complete
failure nonetheless he thanks her and
mentions that he is working on the
second part after a while her husband
Albin approaches them and shakes hands
with James he then invites The Fosters
to join them for dinner that night the
scene then cuts to the dinner where all
the four individuals seem to be having
fun Gabby reveals that she is a
smalltime actor working for commercials
while Albin is an architect when it's
James's turn he mentions that he has not
been able to write any book for the past
six years years fortunately he also has
six ABS this is because he hasn't got
any inspiration for it in response Albin
says that he'll probably get the
inspiration here in Leola he then
suggests that they all go out to observe
the city tomorrow James is a bit
hesitant about it as the country is
known to be very dangerous the resort
officials have clearly warned the
tourists to remain inside the premises
however Albin assures him that it's safe
so they eventually agree the next
morning the four rent a car and exit the
premises after bribing the local guard
they then drive along the coastline
until they arrive at a beautiful spot
the four Park the vehicle and have a
wonderful time by the beach enjoying
drinks and talking about their lives in
the midst of this James gets a sudden
urge to pee so he goes to a corner
surprisingly as he's doing this
something very weird happens Gabby
approaches him from behind and starts
handleing him James also doesn't resist
and she finishes off his hormones it's
one way to put it a few hours later it
gets very dark so the group eventually
decides to leave but since most of them
are excessively drunk James is given the
task of driving along the way they make
several insensitive jokes and talk about
the miserable state of Lola
unfortunately James gets distracted and
ends up hitting a pedestrian the ladder
dies on the spot and this freaks the
group out M suggests contacting the
police but Gabby advises her against it
she mentions that the cops in this
country are very corrupt and if they
find out about this incident they will
surely kill everyone hearing this The
Fosters freak out even more so they
quickly drive back to the resort and go
to sleep the next morning James is
awakened by some loud knocks on the door
when he opens it he finds some cops
outside they have somehow learned about
the incident and are here to arrest The
Fosters after a while James and mem are
brought to the police station for
interrogation the ladder is taken
elsewhere while James is confined in a
shady looking room then detective thresh
shows up and informs him that he killed
an innocent farmer last night according
to the law James will receive the death
penalty to make matters worse the
Executioner will be none other than the
farmer's son who is only 9 years old
James breaks down in tears saying he is
too young to die he continuously pleads
that it was just an accident and he
didn't do it on purpose surprisingly
detective thresh reveals that there is
another rule in this country country
which will allow James to walk away a
free man as per the rule he will have to
pay a substantial amount of money the
government will then clone his body and
give it the death penalty instead the
only stipulation is that James will have
to watch the execution as expected the
latter chooses the second option and is
led to an ATM James takes out a lot of
cash and gives it all to the detective
following this a bunch of Prison
employees begin taking his measurements
guy's shoulders are crazy and his balls
are freaking huge they then fit him with
several weird devices and send him
inside a room there James is instructed
to get inside a pool which is filled
with a strange red liquid as soon as he
does so he experiences numerous Visions
which unsettle him deeply the next thing
he knows he wakes up in a bed sweating
profusely soon his wife M approaches him
and reveals that his clone has been
successfully made she then leads him to
the room and James is taken a back when
he sees his doppelganger they look
exactly the same and the Clone even has
the memory of the original James as well
as the same huge balls after a while the
execution process begins and a lot of
people are gathered to witness it James
and D are also forced to watch as per
the rules soon the 9-year-old boy
arrives in the room with eyes full of
Vengeance he wastes no time and
continuously stabs the helpless clone
who has been tied to a pole m is horri
hor ified by the sight but James seems
to be eerily intrigued that evening the
couple returns to their room and starts
packing their belongings to leave this
country however James suddenly realizes
that his passport is missing he searches
the entire room but fails to find it
shortly after he visits the receptionist
and inquires if she has his passport the
woman answers with a no but says that
she can extend his stay by a week if he
wants James nods his head readily as if
he wants to be here later as he is
walking back to his room Gabby
intercepts him she apologizes for the
entire incident and says that she wants
to share something James doesn't want to
talk to her but after a lot of insisting
he agrees following this the two sit
down and chat over a few drinks Gabby
reveals that several years ago she and
her husband came to this country for the
first time Albin was contracted to build
an infinity pool in a hotel however one
day a freak accident took place which
claimed the lives of two workers Albin
was immediately arrested on the charges
of negligence and this is when they got
to know of the Clones scheme Gabby says
that although it's a strange law it can
be a gift for rich people like them she
also reveals that many tourists come to
Leola only to get a glimpse of their
clones in the next scene Gabby takes
James to her Villa where several
westerners like them are having a fun
time it turns out that they have formed
a secret Community where the members
enjoy killing local people they then pay
the government a lot of money in
exchange for their clones execution
Albin appears to be an integral part of
this community as he was the first one
who discovered the Clone scheme as of
now he is seen sitting with his mistress
but Gabby doesn't seem to care this is
because she too has the liberty of
making out with other men just like
James as the group engages in
conversation one of them proposes that
they raise the stakes tonight they then
decide to infiltrate the resort owner's
house and kill him brutally hearing all
this James is a bit shaken as he
considers the whole thing unethical
however the group eventually convinces
him by saying that they're only going to
have some fun when the clock strikes 12
they arrive at the mansion and ring the
doorbell the maid answers it but she is
immediately subdued the group then
rushes to the main floor and Causes
Chaos the poor owner was in the midst of
a romantic session with his girlfriend
but now both of them have been tied up
after having some fun with them Gabby
hands James a gun and asks him to to
shoot the owner however he refuses to do
so just then the security guard shows up
and Fires at the group Albin is shot in
the leg but before the guard can cause
more damage Gabby shoots him dead during
the chaos the owner his girlfriend and
the maid are also killed in the
aftermath the group brings Albin back to
the resort an Indian dance show is being
displayed so most of the guests are
outside however mem notices the Carnage
and freaks out no matter how hard James
tries to console her he fails the next
morning the entire group is captured and
brought to the police station soon
detective thresh approaches them and
says that they have crossed the line
this time as a consequence they are
going to be punished the scene then cuts
to the execution room where the entire
group is lined up and brutally killed
but then the camera pans to the audience
and we learn that the original group is
still alive turns out they once again
paid the government in exchange for
their freedom later James arrives home
to to find his wife ready to leave she
seems frightened and doesn't want to
stay here anymore surprisingly James
doesn't even try to stop her and says
Lola is my home now after she departs
she meets Gabby at the beach the two
chat for a while before she leads him to
her room there she gives him a local
narcotic which he consumes this makes
him highly excited and the two end up
having passionate coidus as the days
pass James becomes more integrated in
the group and he seems to be enjoying
life he is so high most of the time as
he has developed an addiction for the
narcotic one day during a group meeting
one of the members suggests that they
kidnap detective thresh and eliminate
him the rest of them agree to this
without hesitation including James in
the next scene the group goes to the
police station and forcibly kidnaps the
detective they then bring him to their
Villa and start mistreating him James
once again consumes the narcotic and
goes crazy he beats up the poor
detective and even pees on him the other
members also follow suit and start
urinating soon after Gabby removes the
detective's mask and James is shocked to
discover that the man is none other than
his clone feeling humiliated and upset
he quickly retreats to his room he was
voted most likely to pee on himself in
his high school yearbook but he didn't
see how it was possible James now
realizes that the group is too dangerous
to be around so he retrieves his
passport which he had hid under the sink
and decides es to leave the country
later he quietly boards a bus and makes
his way to the airport unfortunately the
evil group finds out about this and
follows him they intercept the bus
Midway and Gabby points a gun at James
forcing him to come out she then makes
him walk all the way to the resort while
she follows him in her car at an
opportune moment James tries to run away
but Gabby shoots and injures his leg
nevertheless he Ventures deep into the
forest until he loses Consciousness due
to the sever sever loss of blood at this
point all hope seems to be lost and it
appears that James is going to die but
luckily two Good Samaritans spot him and
bring him to their house that night
James experiences terrifying nightmares
which include the murders that he is
committed he also sees the farmer's son
approaching him just then he wakes up to
the sound of some horns when he slowly
makes his way out of the house he finds
the entire group waiting for him then
Gabby steps forward and says that she
wants to play the game if James emerges
Victorious he will be fully integrated
into their group the rules are simple he
will have to kill a dog she then brings
out the dog which turns out to be none
other than James's clone tied to a leash
the Clone appears to be aggressive as if
it is drugged heavily scared James
refuses to be a part of this saying he
wants to go home but when the Clone
attacks him he has no choice but to
fight back despite his injuries he ends
up beating his clone to death in a
gruesome manner in in the aftermath of
the fight James is left bloodied and
traumatized Gabby then approaches him
and does something weird she smears the
blood on her chest and proceeds to
breastfeed
him hello that was a really weird time
to get a phone call in the final scene
the group packs their belongings and
heads to the airport as their vacation
has finally come to an end everyone
talks with one another but James appears
to be silent he is still shocked by what
he experienced here in Lola shortly
after the reach the airport and everyone
boards their respective flights however
James simply stands in the waiting room
after a while he takes a taxi and
returns to the resort perhaps he feels
so guilty that he doesn't want to face
his family or he has started liking the
country and doesn't want to leave at all
the movie ends as James relaxes by the
beach as the rain Pours Down he is still
not sure where his life is heading
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching